Along with behind-the-scenes features and
the occasional Marvel One-Shot, the gag reels
are a favorite staple of Marvel Blu-ray releases.
Fans not only get to laugh, but we also see
the bonds formed behind the scenes.
And it's hard not to fall in love with them
just a little bit.
Here are some of the most hilarious bloopers
and gags waiting on the Thor: Ragnarok Blu-ray.
Butterfingers
One of Mjolnir's amazing properties is that
when Thor wills it back to his hand, it comes
straight away.
Even if the hammer needs to cross nations,
galaxies, or Doctor Strange's entire collection
of sorcerer artifacts, Mjolnir always comes
home.
"Sorry."
Unfortunately, Mjolnir's fantastic abilities
are one thing, and the properties of Thor:
Ragnarok's props are another.
The Blu-ray's gag reel proves that either
someone off-camera wasn't very good at throwing,
or the cast just isn't very good at catching.
This kind of thing is to be expected.
By all appearances, Chris Helssworth has never
been able to catch anything anyway.
Low blows
Thor: Ragnarok included some fantastic leading
female characters.
Cate Blanchett turned in a fun and utterly
vicious portrayal of the lead villain, and
Tessa Thompson was funny, believable, and
badass as Valkyrie.
"He's mine"
And that just makes the number of crotch shots
that happened during filming even more fitting,
especially since almost all of them come unintentionally
from Blanchett, Thompson, or Thompson's stunt
double.
"Are you Okay?"
Pew pew!
You may be familiar with the story that, while
filming lightsaber duels in the Star Wars
prequels, Ewan McGregor had to make an effort
not to make his own lightsaber sounds.
"To begin with it was quite difficult not
to make the sound."
"Yeah."
"Bzzzz and also when it goes away… it makes
that nice sshhhhhhh noise when it goes down."
Well apparently, it's not as uncommon as you'd
think.
The Ragnarok gag reel shows us a number of
shots when Kate Blanchett had to stop because
she realized she was making comic-book sound
effects.
"I shouldn't make the noises with my mouth
should I?"
Warm up
Not everything on the gag reel is a blooper.
Sometimes, perfectly reasonable things like
warming up between takes just looks funny.
"Hey!"
They're not playing to the camera or making
any funny mistakes.
They're just making sure they don't pull a
hamstring when they pretend to be super people
in a couple of minutes.
No harm in that.
All fall down
Maybe it's a side effect of the Revengers'
escape from Sakaar through the "Devil's Anus."
Or maybe director Taika Waititi took the bottomless
mug of beer from the Doctor Strange scene
and passed it around the cast and crew every
day.
But for whatever reason, no one in the cast
of Thor: Ragnarok seemed to be able to stay
upright for more than a few seconds at a time.
What makes their various spills that much
funnier is that it never seems like there's
anything in particular knocking them down.
They don't seem to be in the middle of complicated
action sequences.
They just fall down.
A lot.
"f---"
Avenging bros
While Chris Hemsworth and Mark Ruffalo don't
have the same chemistry going as Iron Man
and Hulk did in The Avengers, they've got
their own buddy feel in Thor: Ragnarok, though
it's definitely more Odd Couple.
"I smashed you."
"Yeah, sure sure"
"Baby arms."
What
"Baby."
"You're a big child."
"Thor go."
"I am going!"
Almost two years before the film's release,
Mark Ruffalo compared the Thor/Hulk relationship
in Ragnarok to the one between Robert De Niro
and Charles Grodin in 1988's Midnight Run.
It's a love/hate relationship, but the two
still share some hilarious moments in the
gag reel.
"I thought you were gone forever I'm glad
to see you back!"
"You're ruining my disguise!"
Unique skill
The Grandmaster of the comics isn't a particularly
fun guy.
Unless you think it's fun to habitually kidnap
superheroes to make them fight for your amusement.
Regardless, Jeff Goldblum's realization of
the character is one of the best reasons to
see Ragnarok.
"You're officially pardoned...from life"
And when he shows up in the gag reel, he definitely
leaves an impression, most notably when he
demonstrates his real life super power:
"Watch this."
Dancing fools
Most of the Marvel gag reels feature bits
of the cast breaking into dance while filming,
and the reel for Thor: Ragnarok is no exception.
But while the cast occasionally cut a rug,
the fanciest feet on the set undoubtedly belonged
to director Taika Waititi, who apparently
never stops dancing.
"A day on the set working with Taika involves
hijinks, dancing, Yeah, he's just a big kid."
In the end, all that play time translated
into an incredibly fun movie, so maybe Taika
Waititi is onto something.
"That is how you make movies."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!